- - C'est le point d'impact d'un
dedes tirs qui se sont abattus
susur Novolouhanske, aujourd'hu.
NoNous sommes dans un poste avaé
dudu commandement de l'armée
ukukrainienne.
L L'ancien garage de machinerie
agagricole est occupé par
leles forces ukrainiennes
dedepuis la guerre en 2014.
" "Ils étaient à 1 10 km",
raraconte le lieutenant-major
AnAnatoly, qui commande
lala compagnie sur place
àà s son général.
C C'était autour de 11 h
cece matin. L'un de ses soldats,
VlVladimir, a été atteint
papar le projectile.
" "Tout va bien, tout va bien",
lului dit une des secouristes
popour le rassurer.
LeLe jeune homme de 25 ans
a a survécu à s ses blessures,
mamais on a dû l l'amputer.
V Vladimir est l'un des quatre
sosoldats ukrainiens blessés
auaujourd'hui. Deux autres,
dodont un officier, ont été tué.
C Comme nous nous apprêtotons à
reregagner le bâtitiment princil
dudu poste, les tirs reprennent.
(t(tirs)
ViVite, on nous met à l l'abri.
PrPrès s d'une vingtaine de tirs
vovont s'abattre sur Novolouhane
etet ses environs au cours de
cecette nouvelle attaque, forçat
mmêmeme le ministre de l'Intérir
enen visite dans les tranchées
àà c courir aux abris.
C Ça fait maintenant une
vivingtaine de minutes qu'on a û
sese mettre à l l'abri parce que
leles tirs ont repris le genre e
viviolation des accords de Minsk
quque les soldats disent voir
dede plus en plus ici : des tirs
d'd'armes interdits à q quelque
5 5 à 1 10 km de leur position.
(t(tirs)
T Tout au long de la ligne
dede contact avec les rebelles
séséparatistes dans un
cecessez-le-feu qui se transfore
enen chimèrere, les autorités
ukukrainiennes ont rapporté
9898 violations du cessez-le-feu
auaujourd'hui seulement.
(t(tir)
L Les observateurs internationx
ququalifient l'augmentation des
dederniers jours de spectaculai.
AuAu risque de donner l'image
d'd'un président absent en pleie
crcrise, c'est à M Munich que st
rerendu le président ukrainien,
VoVolodymyr Zelensky, pour plair
avavec l'Occident. I Il a répéta
dedemande de sanctions immédiats
cocontre la Russie.
" "Pour vraiment aider l'Ukrai,
çaça ne sert à r rien, dit-il,
dede parler de possibles dates
d'd'invasion. Nous allons
dédéfendre notre pays, que ce st
lele 16 février, le 1er mars
ouou le 31 décembre."
A À Moscou, c'est une image
ininversée que l'on présente dea
sisituation, accusant les forces
ukukrainiennes d'êtrtre à l l'oe
dede l'intensification deses ti.
VlVladimir Poutine envoyait
vivisiblement un message
enen assistant à d des tests de
mimissiles dotés de la capacité
nunucléaire.
C Chez les séparatistes,
dadans la république autoproclae
dede Donetsk, on se prépare à ce
ququ'on décrit comme une situatn
crcritique. Les autorités
onont ordonné la mobilisation
dedes hommes en âgege de combate
alalors que des milliers de fems
etet d'enfants ont pris la route
vevers la Russie.
L Les accusations voulant
quque l'armée ukrainienne est
susur le point d'attaquer sont
cacatégoriquement démenties du
ccôtété ukrainien de la frontiè:
"C"C'est faux.
N Nous n'avons aucun plan
dede reconquêtete, a dit
lala vice-premièrere ministre. t
lala Fédération russe qui retiet
lala population en otage."
I Ici Marie Ève Bédard,
R Radio-Canada, Novolouhanske